Tracy and Phaedra are here I'm so
excited but I feel like I should have
maybe even call you say drah now you're
almost a branch did I come to the tea
yeah
how well did you guys know each other
before we got the Phaedra invasion oh we
really didn't know each other like that
we we've always loved each other from
afar and now we're up please oh yeah now
you're like oh my god oh my god Phaedra
Parks and Traci Braxton are now besties
after Phaedra stepped in to film a
Braxton Family Values so we're gonna
shut down when Tracy's family went on
strike did you hear from any of her
sisters directly or indirectly in
directly but Phaedra this could be your
new full-time reality TV home do you
think this could be a full-time fit for
you you know I never rule out anything
and I love being around Traci we have a
ball when we're together and I think we
bring out the best in each other so I
think it's a match made in
so you know I love it but do you want to
return to reality TV full-time or just
kind of you know what my first part is
being a mom you know and so I want my
boys to be able to watch me and be proud
of me I want to do televisions that
edifies women and empowers women and I
want to if I do reality I want it to be
real and so what I was doing with them
was really real so you know every moment
you will see it's real and it's very
organic and so I can feel good about at
the end of the day there's no stress
associated with it those things you
listed the edifies women that's real do
you feel like that was missing from your
last reality TV experience
no I'm living in the present you know I
was with you know housewives for eight
years no regrets but this is very
different I have seen the dark side of
reality TV I've been in the dark side we
set some records straight about
housewives wait a minute we don't have
no TV had enough tea up in here but
nobody was sip and 91 could assume there
were some rumors out there that you were
spotted filming with candy for the new
season
oh no would you ever return to that show
I have no plans to but I would never say
never but I'm very happy with what I'm
doing now like you said no regrets I'm
happy I mean you left we didn't have a
clean exit if you were to go back to
that show just for one episode to close
the book on it and give the fans
something what would you say nothing
okay would you have anything to say to
candy I mean whatever I've said I've
already said you know that was Nell two
years ago so yes I'm living in 2018
living in 2018 living on WE tv yes are
you still in contact with anybody from
that show several of them
um just last with Mimi last with three
days ago
okay you know I just saw Sheree in the
park maybe we could go and so of course
the me and Porsha are in contact Frick
and frack is still alive what should be
all upset and everything cuz I'm jumping
abuela freeze lady we give a back I'm
gonna give a back portion we're just
gonna come up that's tricking frac you
guys can be something else they obey
dress
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]